think about all the things that you
thought you once knew
that you thought were certain or true
that you later learned to be false
descartes begins the first meditation by
simply observing
how many doubtful opinions he's had in
his life and maybe you're like that too
[Music]
so descartes thinks
how can i know anything
for certain
and so he proposes to himself a method
he proposes what he calls a complete
demolition
of all of his opinions
until he can find
something
that he knows
for certain
he gives himself a rule
i'm gonna doubt everything i could
possibly doubt
and see if there's anything left
that makes sense if certain
doubts are there and you want to find
something you know for certain peel
everything else away and so he gives
himself that rule as part of his
strategy in the meditations
he proceeds in the first meditation in
three stages
he starts with the senses
he observes that his senses have
deceived him before that's stage one and
when someone deceives you he points out
that usually means they're not credible
they're not reliable and so you doubt
them
descartes then raises a second
stage objection
he says well
sometimes i've dreamed
things that seemed so real that in the
dream
i was sure i was in reality until i woke
up
so how do i know i'm not dreaming right
now
this is a famous dream argument
could you be dreaming right now
that you're watching this video
now i'm not asking whether you think
you're dreaming but is it possible
that you're dreaming right now that this
is part of a dream the skeptical
descartes responds with a third stage of
the argument
this is called the evil genius argument
he says we think that there's a god
that's omnipotent
and omniscient
why couldn't there be a being
that could deceive us
why couldn't it be the case
that while we think we're having all
these experiences in the world
in fact they're simply
being projected into our minds
say by electrodes
if you are of a certain age and you're
watching this
video right now you may think
immediately of the movie the matrix
you remember that it begins with the
lead character neo having all these
experiences which seem normal
and then over the course of the movie he
discovers that all of those experiences
have been
stimulated artificially into his mind
while he has remained inside a pod
in philosophy this is sometimes called
the brain and the vat
argument
and the question is
is it possible
that you are merely a brain in a vat
and that
all the experiences you think of the
external world
are simply
artificial stimulations inside your
brain to give you those experiences
it would be
similar to sitting
to your sitting inside a cave
your mind is inside a cave and you have
windows on the cave and you think you
see all this reality outside the windows
but actually the windows are simply
video projections so all your life you
think i'm seeing reality through those
windows your eyes for example be in the
windows but it's not out there
and
not surprisingly following this line of
argument
descartes ends the first meditation
in a bit of an abyss
he begins the second meditation
almost in despair
he has demolished
through his methodological skepticism
every single plausible belief he's at
sea
doubt
but then he asks
am i not then at least something
but i've already denied that i have any
senses
and any body
still i hesitate for what falls from
this
am i so tied
to a body
into the senses that i cannot exist
without them
but i have persuaded myself that there
is absolutely nothing in the world
no sky no earth no minds no bodies is it
then the case that i too do not exist
but doubtless
i did exist if i persuaded myself of
something
it's just a basic argument descartes
expresses it this way very famously
the famous articulation is
i think
therefore
i am
i think therefore i am but what he's
leading to here is even a better
expression
i am an error
i know nothing therefore i
am
even if he is deceived by the evil
genius about basic math
descartes suggests
i must
exist to be deceived
and so the cogito or actually eggo the i
becomes the archimedean point
of descartes world the modern school of
athens
it would have descartes pointing
to himself in the center of the painting
whereas bacon would be pointing down
descartes seeks to re-ground philosophy
on the eagle on the self on self
knowledge
what kind of self
has descartes
actually
found
notice how abstract it is
he's told us because of the
methodological doubt it doesn't have
senses it doesn't have a body
it doesn't have memory
that's not the ego it's not the ego that
was born
to certain parents had six brothers and
sisters went through life none of those
does that ego know it knows none of it
except
that it's an error and so it must exist
you